what's up I'm in New Orleans I'm
attending new RPS this week if you're
here come say hi love to meet you yeah
so we have to talk about Gemini and the
whole disaster around the fake video I
guess so we'll see about that who deep
mind has released a new model called
Gemini it is a large multimodal model I
guess it's no longer appropriate to call
them llms now that they're not language
only anymore but it is a transform that
consumes sort of images and text and
audio and so on and outputs I believe it
outputs images and text and yeah it does
all in all and it's big how big we have
no idea now there has been a bit of
controversy around a demo video that
they released and that people later said
it's staged or Faked and so on they're
outraged about it now honestly I
personally am not that upset about it
I'm also not that impacted or surprised
or anything anything like this like the
fact that this is big news I get it a
little bit but also I don't really get
it so we'll dive into the video and you
know what the controversy behind it is
later but I want to say if you're
looking to be upset about something much
more upset about the rest of the Gemini
release than the demo video they made
you know to put a nice music behind it
and tell a nice story like the rest of
what they did is much more upsetting so
let's look at that this website right
here welcome to the Gemini area this is
wow this is Gemini it's multimodality
texting blah blah blah yes this is a
marketing page but even in marketing
pages I believe you should be somewhat
somewhat honest and this graphic right
here is one of the things that I think
is kind of a lot more upsetting than the
video so they compare GPT 4 to Gemini
Ultra which is the largest Gemini model
look at that that if Gemini Ultra is
prompted with Chain of Thought prompting
it's a prompting technique uh it's
relatively intensive but it gives good
results in sort of very complex language
understanding tasks wellas GPT 4 is
prompted with five shot prompts so
naturally a Chain of Thought prompt is
going to deliver much better results
than a just five shot prompt on a Model
just displaying this graphic right here
as it is of with the big numbers like
ooh Gemini 90 qp4
86.4 human expert 89.8 right just
displaying them like this with like a
tiny font that says how they were
achieved is to me not very cool in fact
if you look at the technical report so
let's go to the part where the results
are if you look at that you can find
these numbers again Gemini Ultra
9.04 and GPT 4 86.4 four in Chain of
Thought and five shot now here's the
kicker if you look at Gemini Ultra five
shot prompted it's worse than gp4 if
they however evaluate gp4 with Chain of
Thought prompting it is better than the
five shot prompted model but not as good
as the Gemini Ultra the kicker here is
that these aren't verified numbers these
are just numbers that they got via the
API of gp4 these are numbers by the gp4
team themselves
so now you can see how this number came
about namely they found themselves in a
bit of a tussle right there is a very
important Benchmark that they want to be
really good at and they have a method to
be really good at this this one
prompting strategy with their model
turns out to be really really good
better than humans even right however
they don't have comparable numbers for
that particular prompting strategy what
they do have comparable numbers for is
this five shot thing but oh wouldn't it
be great if they would also be better on
that but they're not in this prompting
method gp4 is better so what do they do
they can't come out with a model and say
well we Compare the numbers and actually
on this important one were worse and
they also can't really I guess they
could have put the 87 here I get they
want to do compare to reported numbers
but yeah so you can see the conundrum
they found themselves in it's still I
think not very okay to represent it like
that I personally would have probably
put the the 87 here I guess that would
have drawn some some attention from the
open AI folks in any case the marketing
page here there's not too much more
there's a bunch of these numbers and
then uh a bunch of nice graphics and so
on a bunch of oo what can it do oh wow I
want to go into the technical report a
bit this is what I find to be the one of
the most upsetting things papers aren't
papers anymore they're not technical
reports because in a technical report
you can write anything that you want and
have to disclose nothing and that's I
think what's upsetting to me I come from
a time as an academic where we wrote
papers and we actually put inside of the
papers what we did and how we did it so
that others could reproduce it and
that's just not the case anymore with
these big releases this technical report
here is essentially just another
marketing piece and why do I say that
because they say next to nothing in this
technical report they open with this
example right here of Gemini solving or
correcting a student that incorrectly
solves a physics problem which is neat
it's supposed to show that Gemini can
unify language and images and
handwritten and physics knowledge and
then do some calculations even at the
end that's certainly I guess impressive
but yeah it's an example and honestly
like 90% of the answer here on the right
hand side you can get by recognizing
just like one or two lines like as long
as you recognize the student wrote E
equals mgl you can probably already
guess what went wrong and what should go
right and then you kind of have to get
the numbers here right not saying it's
not impressive but uh it's an example
right so they want to show oh look what
it can what it all can do so then the
next thing they do is they tell us oh
our model comes in different sizes wow
that's interesting the model comes in
size Ultra Pro and Nano at least for the
Nano they say how big it is they say
it's 1.8 billion and 3.25 billion
parameters the Nanos are meant to be run
on device and yeah the 1.8 billion 4bit
quanti would clock in I would say about
just under a gigabyte of RAM which is
probably a manable to a lot of devices
and yeah it's going to be cool future
where these things run on device and
good that they actually tell us how big
they are we would find out anyway
because they would be deployed on
devices and people are going to inspect
them however for the pro and the ultra
they just say well the pro is meant to
be something and the ultra is meant to
be like bigger than the pro we have no
they could have just as well said we
trained Gumble and Bumble it's it's all
the same they don't share anything any
facts about this the biggest kicker like
the thing that actually upsets me is the
architecture diagram they have done a
great deal to go into the architecture
of these models the detail that they
have put into these architecture
diagrams and the Novelties and The
Innovation that can be deduced from that
is astounding are you ready for the
architecture diagram of the century wow
[Music]
there it
is there seems to be inputs those inputs
will get into what looks to be tokens it
goes into a Transformer and then there
are outputs this is amazing I cannot
stop looking at this this is so
bad I guess we can pull out there there
there is image text audio and video
inputs and then there is image and text
outputs like that's fine but really
really this
uh then they come to the training
infrastructure where they kind of detail
how they went about training the thing
and then what kind of chips and sure
they here and there they say something
about what they did to solve the
problems but they're super careful to
never say anything so that you could
even estimate or guesstimate how big the
models are or how much compute they put
into it or something like this like
they're extremely careful to to like say
a lot of words without saying really a
lot of things they do go a little bit
into as I said how they handled Hardware
failures and things like this but
essentially they say nothing and from
here it just gets worse it just gets
worse they use a sentence piece
tokenizer oh by the way the models are
32k tokens that's they say that but
other than that the further down you go
the less they say until we get to the
evaluation and the evaluation is just
the number numbers that I've shown you
before these are fairly extensive so
they do fairly extensive evaluations on
a lot of benchmarks but then again as
soon as you could estimate something is
like relative sizes again and so on but
yeah the evaluations I have to say are
good so they compare as you can see
there's lots of numbers um Yes again
look at that wow is what's the label
your axis like what's the unit in any
case they have some examples on how it
can create uh matplot lib code and so on
it's pretty good like I'm honestly
excited about these models like they're
going to be cool to work with they're
going to be cool to try they're going to
be cool to build applications upon they
seem to be really capable I'm just not
haven't arrived yet in the new world
where it's just well we made something
and you may use it via our API
but we won't tell you anything about it
Gemini is further step towards our
mission to solve intelligence Advance
science and benefit Humanity you're not
you're doing the opposite of that not
the opposite but you're very actively
trying not to do that all right let's
get into video controversy so there's
been this video they've released this
okay we've been testing the capabilities
of Gemini and look how it how it kind of
looks so look how they phrase it here
IDE let's start all right testing Gemini
here we go tell me what you see I see
you placing a piece of paper on the
table I see a squiggly
line what about now the contour lines
are smooth and flowing with no sharp
angles or Jagged
edges it looks like a bird to me hm what
if I add
this the bird is swimming in the water
it has a long neck and Beak it is a duck
yes a duck is a type of waterf in the
family inad clue one this country is the
home of the kangaroo the koala and the
Great Barrier Reef oh that's
easy clue two this country loves
football and has won the most men's
World Cups in football history
H find the paper ball under the cup I
accept the
challenge the cup to the
left I know what you're doing you're
playing rock paper scissors all right
this was this was probably the biggest
controversy the rock paper scissors one
they made this video and they put a nice
voice on Gemini and it's kind of
interactive and so on and then in the
blog post they released along with that
they said you know how it's made how how
how the video is made and they reveal
how they made the video for example they
show a frame of the video and then they
give a prompt and this is already
there's so many news articles oh Google
Faces controversy over edited Gemini AI
demo video all the video was fabricated
why do people say that because it turns
out they've just shown appropriate
frames from the videos and then giving
prompts together with those frames then
they took the out output of Gemini and
then they had someone say it or they had
a voice voice as text to speech say it
so they didn't actually show the video
isn't a live interaction with Gemini
that recognizes from the video frames
and so on and the prompts sometimes are
also quite helpful for example this one
what do you think I'm doing hint it's a
game right showing these three frames
which is I get it it's really different
than what we just saw what we just saw
was a person just doing this and then
this and then this and then Gemini by
itself said I know what you're doing
you're playing rock paper scissors there
is a big difference yeah so people are
quite upset that the prompts were quite
specific and only individual frames were
shown and that the video wasn't this
live interaction and so on however like
that to me that's kind of the least
worrying part I didn't know what you
expect but that's what I expected when I
saw this video when I saw this video I
was like like okay they must be like
either snapshotting the frames or doing
something like this right very clearly
uh or they just tried 50 billion times
right that's the other thing what what
do you expect what do you expect
continuous video feed interactive thing
that's just not the case nowadays so I
kind of expected that I guess the
regular journalist from CNBC didn't they
actually believe that this was an
interactive system I didn't and uh
therefore I wasn't that upset about it
I'm personally much more upset about all
the other stuff about the fact that they
wrote a technical report and didn't say
a single thing that's actually useful
about these models so make up your own
minds honestly I think it's fine to do
marketing for marketing sakes even
making these videos and so on to me not
that big of a deal honestly uh what
matters is what kind of applications
people build on top of these types of
things and honestly something that takes
frames and uh prompts is much more
useful than something that is
interactive video tell me what you see
kind of stuff all right that was it from
me for Gemini and at least the
controversy around this if you find out
how Big Gemini Ultra is please post it
in a comment other than that I will be
at NPS I'll see you around and
[Music]
bye-bye
oh